mom just told me that it was melanoma
this on her face is very concerning I
don't think I've seen you this slow well
he's Health Scare at the center of the
Kardashians season three this was way
more serious than I anticipated it to be
in the new trailer for The Hulu reality
series back May 25th the famous fans
concerned about Coco's drastic weight
loss amid her deadly health issue mom
just told me that it was melanoma this
on her face is very concerning I don't
think I've seen you this slow she
doesn't sleep she's lost a lot of weight
melanoma's deadly this was way more
serious than I anticipated it to be yeah
that's Chloe's stitched up face in
October she revealed in detail she
underwent a procedure to have a tumor
removed something she says she assumed
was something as minor as is it Khloe
was told she needed an immediate
operation to have it removed by the time
she shared it with fans she was already
in the healing process I think for every
sister we have different boundary levels
and we all try to respect that as far as
Coco's weight loss goes well we know she
goes beast mode in the gym working out
is one of my new obsession healthy
obsessions but in January the reality
star had to shut down rumors that she
was shedding lbs because of semi-glue
tide and anti-diabetic injectable used
for chronic weight management most
notably it sold under the name ozempic
which is rumored to be abused by
Hollywood stars to drop weight fast but
Coco slammed the claim saying let's not
discredit my years of working out I get
up five days a week at 6 a.m to train
that's bizarre to me and you would think
people would be happy
that I'm staying healthy and fit Health
scare aside seems Chloe's doing well
amid her recovery in February she
updated fans who asked about her cheek
responding I'm totally okay such a
beautiful thing so why is Chloe sharing
her story she says it's to remind
everyone to make regular visits to the
doctor I wish I could tell you this is
going to be a mild relaxing Serene
season
it's not what is in the media is sort of
things that we feel we need to film
because it's
in a way unfair to the viewers if they
don't get to see that we've shared so
much about our lives we've been doing
this for so long
[Music]